Disney Channel was a part of most of our
childhoods but as you grow up you
realize just how unrealistic some of
these shows were fans of some of your
favorite childhood shows came up with
some pretty believable theories and
we're going to break them down today
seriously some of these will hit you
right in your heart can you guess which
popular character is supposed to have
schizophrenia stay tuned to find out if
you were right in the sweet life okay
guys let's start light the suite life on
deck isn't as old as some of the other
shows we'll talk about today but for
many it was still a vital part of their
childhood the show is all about the
twins zack and cody martin they end up
living at the top of the five-star
Tipton hotel the key word in this theory
is the last name Tipton do you guys
remember london tipton she's one of the
main characters on the show she's known
to be kind of a dead - super selfish at
the time but it honestly depends on her
mood ah the life of their rich right
while this theory brings a whole new
perspective on London remember when she
was asked if she brought a picture of
herself and a person that was described
as you know who London immediately
replied Voldemort it was the moment when
two of our fav worlds collided and then
this theory happened it's actually a
chain of responses from tumblr and
honestly it kind of makes sense
everyone thought London was a ditz but
at that moment people started giving her
more credit but this theory goes even
further saying that what if London's
actually a witch who just doesn't
understand the muggle world it would
also explain why she never saw her
parents because they'd always be at the
Ministry another tumblr user said that
London is a squib which means she was
born in a Wizarding family but doesn't
have any powers the next user then said
what if she actually had powers and hid
them and basically just pretended she
was a ditz she wanted to work with
muggles so she became one with the
society and the next user added that it
would explain why she can't really use
everyday muggle objects in case you
forgot London isn't really clumsy of
course this entire exchange was just an
exaggerated joke in the true style of
Tumblr but what if it actually was true
we have to give London
hanna montana' if you weren't onboard
with the sweet life you were most likely
a hard-core Hannah Montana fan let's be
honest Hannah Montana created some of
the best moments on the Disney Channel
plus it pretty much made Miley Cyrus a
household name Hannah Montana has had
several theories over the years and will
break down some of the most popular ones
have you ever heard of the one where
everyone already knows that Miley is
Hannah
you'll want to rewatch the show after
this one just so you can imagine it in
this way so basically this theory states
that Hannah's dad Robbie ray made
everyone pretend they don't know Miley
is Hannah this was done in order so that
Miley could live a regular life
Robbie ray wanted her to have a normal
childhood and it was clear she wasn't
going to get it another Hannah Montana
theory states that Hannah's wig is more
magical than we think you know how with
the wig on Hannah was basically
unrecognizable even though Miley would
still look very similar to her so what
if Hannah's wig holds a magical hypnotic
powers she might not even know about
them herself and if you think about it
it's pretty suspicious that everyone
immediately bought into the fact that
Miley looks like a completely different
person with a wig like come on it's just
a regular wig not impressed yet don't
worry we're just warming up moving on to
another nostalgic fave Wizards of
Waverly Place Wizards of Waverly Place
has an extremely popular theory that's
actually a crossover with Hannah Montana
and the suite life on deck this one is
actually kind of believable considering
the crossover happened in real life in
case you don't remember it you have to
revisit 2009 and experience all its
glory it was an absolutely epic moment
for fans of all three shows but it also
created a huge plot hole here's an
existential question for you since
Selena Gomez was both Mikayla skeet and
Alex Russo how would this even work if
the characters met in real life
especially since the show's existed in
the same universe for the first time
ever Hannah and Alex conveniently never
cross paths in the crossover episode but
they were on a cruise ship together at
the same time like come on they would
have met eventually right it's not like
the cruise ship was that big but if
Hannah ever saw Alex she would recognize
her as Michaela the pop star
from Hannah Montana so our Disney
Channel universe would pretty much
implode the tumblr user called wayfaring
and whatnot sort of explains how both
Alex and Mikaela were able to exist
during this epic crossover this tumblr
user said that the characters can't
exist simultaneously unless Alex Russo
created a popstar
alter-ego and used magic to never be
recognized for it if you think about it
this would tie with the theory that
Miley has a magical wig considering she
pretty much never gets recognized and if
Alex would actually be using magic she
could get away with a lot more we're not
gonna lose we're gonna OH Teen Vogue
pointed out that Alex did change reality
in Wizards of Waverly Place
the movie so this would actually makes
sense so did Alex blue a Miley and also
masquerade herself into a pop star
during that crossover and not just
during a crossover but also during the
actual Hannah Montana Alex all along
okay this theory actually gave us a
headache
so let's just move on thanks for that
plot hole though Disney Kim Possible
okay now this theory is actually really
believable we love female superhero
characters because they're incredibly
inspiring for young girls and women but
what if Kim Possible had another hidden
side to her that she never really
revealed Jim KP Gina bull see bleh if
you think about it kim is incredibly
advanced for her age especially since
she's so athletic she doesn't even look
like a typical teenager in the first
place but her athleticism is honestly
surprising considering the move she
makes
you think she'd trained hard 24/7 but we
never see her train teenagers would also
need extra motivation to do that not to
mention she'd have to watch which she
eats and make sure she maintains her
muscles that that's not the case for Kim
a reddit user said that Kim Possible was
genetically altered the theory argues
that both of Kim's parents were
scientists one of these scientists
actually created Kim and made her strong
and athletic no matter what like Hulk of
her generation if you will which pretty
much means she's not human in any way
but gets to live a regular human life
there's a lot of weird stuff that
happens in Kim Possible anyways so maybe
this wouldn't be so crazy after all but
then again this would mean that Kim is
definitely not a basic average girl but
we already know that don't we all right
that was
a good one but we're not done yet on to
the next one we love it when theories
about childhood shows get dark because
it shows us just how differently we
think now that we're older of course you
have to take these theories with a grain
of salt because that's all they are just
theories do you remember the show recess
it's an old show from almost two decades
ago but honestly it's fabulous it's all
about a group of friends and their
experiences during school breaks and
here's the theory well shorten it just a
bit but you could read it in full length
at quota be calm and honestly it's worth
the read basically this theory questions
white kids in recess never age as the
show goes on the kids always stay the
same well this theory points out that
there might be a darker reason behind
that it starts with the fact that all
characters were born after the first
world war TJ was one of the first
students to attend and he was an
inspirational leader who was trying to
become fourth great president at the
time when the Great Depression hits the
principal of his school made budget cuts
to school lunches there was a process
and unfortunately TJ got hit by an ice
cream truck
stick with us promise it's worth it the
theory goes on to say that TJ's ghost
remained on the playground ever since
his human version got hit the ghost
encouraged other kids to stand up for
themselves too
eventually the school had to close down
because so many kids lost their lives
the ghost never left the playground and
they only pretend to have school breaks
the truth is they'll never be able to go
back to real school ever again
honestly we're totally on board with
this but we really recommend you read
the whole thing because it gives an
amazing breakdown of every single recess
character and how they became a ghost
Lizzie McGuire and last but not least
it's our fave 90 show ever
kids these days probably know the magic
that is Lizzie McGuire and if you don't
you absolutely have to watch it it's a
fabulous show that's still relevant
today and don't forget about the iconic
movie that's arguably better than the
show itself seriously Disney nailed it
with this one and we're forever thankful
but that's not what we're here to talk
about this is all about crazy theories
and honestly this one is the craziest I
read a theory states that Lizzie McGuire
is all about a girl that's showing signs
of schizophrenia these symptoms can be
clearly seen in her alter ego she's the
only one that can see and hear that
alter ego we often see the cartoon
version of the
and Lizzie come out whenever she's stuck
in a situation often cartoon Lizzie will
also make an appearance when she wants
to say something she can't if the real
Lizzie needs to rant the cartoon Lizzie
will come out that already sounds weird
right the reddit user also says that
Miranda isn't real either she's just a
figment of Lizzie's imagination this is
also why Miranda disappears by the end
of middle school this theory states that
Lizzie started taking her medication and
Miranda was no longer needed this is
where the movie part of Lizzie McGuire
comes in
oh and spoiler alert in case you haven't
seen it Lizzie becomes more stable her
parents allow her to travel to Rome with
school but things take a turn for the
worst once again after Lizzie believe
she's talking to an Italian pop star she
even thinks that she looks like a pop
star herself and can suddenly sing even
after years and years of stage fright
she also totally hallucinate at that
entire award show moment truth be told
this would make sense considering her
actual pop star look-alike joined her on
stage we'd like to add that this is what
dreams are made of lyrics seem fitting
because the awards show is everything
the schizophrenic Lizzie could dream of
plus it has the most perfect happy
ending ever
honestly the schizophrenia theory is
totally believable but then again this
would definitely make everything a lot
more dark we'd like to keep Lizzie
McGuire bright and bubbly thank you very
much yeah yeah we know we just ruined
Lizzie McGuire for you but make sure to
tell us what you think in the comments
below do you have your own Disney
Channel theories share them with the
rest of us and let's discuss and that's
it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more
feel-good content thanks for watching
see you next time